[Music]  it's time I cook I like a paradigm shift  because we find that everything we were  taught in our life with a lie now we got  to figure out hope there's not too late  for to figure out what's really going on  who the [ __ ] I really am what was like  Socrates saying that he knows that he  don't know no one knows anything  I had to becoming partly 40 10 then I  have to find out who am i what is my  purpose here we don't know our purpose  we've been put here for a reason that we  have no idea what it is this is where it  gets tricky you know it's a beautiful  ride then sometimes it ends away with a  [ __ ] Michael this can't just end like  this I get all like dionyse don't gonna  wear that black that's gonna be the next  test of your journey where do I go from  here  the feeling so so sensation about you  yes it's like you feel like your star or  a furnace exploded  [Applause]  you